هكذا
الامل الاوكراني في مقاتلات اف 16 بدت
واشنطن في حمله الامداد بالدبابات رائده
للحلف الغربي فهل يحسم النفي الرئاسي
الامريكي التردد بين حلفاء كياب بشان
المقاتلات الامريكيه لماذا تريد اوكرانيا
التزود بمقاتلات اف 16 هي تعاني حاليا
تراجعا في مخزون صواريخ الدفاع الجوي ما
ينذر بعجز محتمل عن مواجهه المقاتلات
والمسيرات روسيه كما انها تستعد لما يعرف
بهجوم الربيع الذي تخطط له سعيا لاستعاده
ما سقط من اراضيها في يد الروس
التجاوب الامريكي ثم الغربي في الامداد
بالدبابات رفع مستوى توقعات الاوكرانيين
المترقبين لطائرات اف 16 لدرجه تجهيز
قائمه ل 50 طيارا اوكرانيا مستعدين
للتدريب على المقاتله اف 16 لمده ثلاثه
اشهر تفوق السرعه الى اف 16 سرعه الصوت
وتبلغ 2000 و 400 كلم في الساعه ولها
القدره على الطيران في جميع الاحوال
الجويه والتزود بالوقود جوا كما يمكنها
حمل سته صواريخ جو جو ومدفع متعدد الفوهات
وذخائر جو جو وجو ارض فضلا عن القدره على
المناوره وضرب الاهداف على الارض والطيران
على ارتفاع المنخفض لتفادي الرادارات
الارضيه لذلك لن يكون التدريب على
استخدامها سريعا ولا سهلا بل قد يستغرق
الربيع المنتظر واكثر بالنظر ايضا لسابق
خبرات الطيارين الاوكرانيين البعيده عن
التقنيات الامريكيه وهي احد الاسباب
الفنيه للتحفظ الامريكي بجانب متطلبات
بنيه تحتيه لتشغيل طائرات اف سته عشر قد
لا تكون متوفره في الساحه الاوكرانيه لكن
الدوافع السياسيه للموقف الامريكي اشد
اهميته فلا تخفي واشنطن منذ بدء الحرب
رفضها للتصعيد ضد رو بشكل يورطها هي في
مواجهه مباشره وهو ليس تحفظا امريكيا فقط
فحتى الرئيس الفرنسي الذي لم يغلق الباب
تماما امام تزويد اوكرانيا بطائرات مقاتله
اعتبر عدم الجنوح للتصعيد ضد روسيا شرطا
اساسيا بل ان رئيس الوزراء البولنديه الذي
قالت اوكرانيا انها تلقت منه اشارات
ايجابيه بشان تزويدها بمقاتلات اف 16 قال
ان الامر سيتم بتنسيق كامل مع النيتو وهو
اعتبار قد يواجه بعراق قيل امريكيه داخل
الحلف يعرف الروس فيما يبدو استغفر
العربيه لدعم اوكرانيا ولذلك علق
الكريملين على الموقف البولندي المتقدم
وقال الناطق باسمه بمتر ديسكو ان بولندا
والدول البلطيق مستعده لفعل كل ما يزيد
المواجهه مع روسيا دون نظر للعواقب